i was reading some statistic where like
they thought that it was gonna sell a
quarter million games
and it sold
five million
i have a funny story about that actually
as as the uh
as the game was getting released
they could sense the buzz of it i was
just going a million miles an hour
because i was still doing x games and i
was yeah i was just like
like i was working on the game i know i
was proud of it but i just didn't
imagine it was gonna be big
and
they called me right before the release
and they said um we want to offer you a
buyout of future loyalties
pieces of [ __ ] oh my god did the red
flag go off right there did you realize
no are you kidding me i'd like they said
we want to buy you off for a half a
million dollars yeah
at that time in my life yeah someone
saying a half million dollars sounded
like a gazillion billion
and uh
and i had just i just moved into a new
house
um i like i was getting pretty good
royalties still i was starting to make
good money just from being a pro skater
right and i told him i got you know what
i think i'm going to take a chance
go for it if i hadn't bought that house
right then i probably would have taken
whoa
but i had just like i said bought a new
house and was able to pay the mortgage
which is something that uh was new to me
being able to afford the mortgage on my
house
um and so i took a chance and it was
definitely the best financial decision
in my life so were you i mean i don't
want to you know get in your pockets too
much here but
i do want to
but so did they give you like a piece of
the game or like how does it work with
uh yeah royalties yeah so you just get a
percentage of every game
yeah and all the money that comes with
the game etc
uh if they sell merch or they sell yes
yeah a lot of a lot of stuff happened
um based on the success of the game i
got all kinds of different
endorsements
and licensing deals and i i definitely
attribute that to
success
the thing that that was the
real
silver lining to all of it was that all
of the skaters had a deal that
if it reaches these certain marks of
sales they get a piece they get more
they get almost what they signed up for
and
that original crew of skaters did really
well that's great okay
now this makes a little more sense i
always wondered how the [ __ ] you were so
at least appeared so liked by these
people you would just body in every
competition
like every competition you're destroying
and then i see them on the side of
halfpipe they're hitting the half pipe
they're like they're rooting for this
person that is
there's only one person in their way of
gold
how did they like you i but okay that is
but that's just not just me that is
skateboard okay in a nutshell okay
it's an individual pursuit but
everyone's pulling for each other so
that's part of the community
if you go to a skate park you see
someone that's trying to nail something
you see everyone rally around them
and maybe
maybe
later on you'll compete against them but
but at some point it's more like you
want to see them succeed and and
absolutely there was some cutthroat
competition through the years and
and
people had uh issues with scores and all
that kind of thing but but that was
never the that was never the narrative
did they thought you got favorable score
or vice versa
it was more was it jordan rules for tony
hawk was that
actually i
i think that through my years especially
in the um in late 80s and then
afterwards in the late 90s
i i know this definitely happened i
started getting judged for what they
thought i was capable of
as opposed to what
was against everyone else interesting so
if you want and that gets really yeah
that gets that gets weird when you're
you want to be seen as a peer to all
your competitors
but the judges see you as well this is
what we saw him do last time you're
chasing your own ghost
yeah and even if that even if what you
did last time could be the best
performance of the event
there's still like he's got to step it
up right so we're going to mark him down
for that
um same thing happened to rodney mullen
yeah of course i heard simone biles was
saying that in the olympics that they're
judging her based off like the other
competitions and not i can smoke
everybody else here but
yeah and that gets really and that gets
isolating because then all your
competitors are just like
yeah
you know they they don't even really
identify with you right wait what do you
mean by that um
well let's put it this way when i was
competing especially in the 80s i would
get i would
the people who i'd love skating with and
respected they'd be like oh man i'm just
hoping to get second
really yeah so you were that far
above
did you have like a kelly slater-esque
run would you see that as your
competition like the way that kelly was
just on a different level was surfing um
i definitely had a run of success like
that yeah it but in terms of the
discrepancy between you and the other
people not always it wasn't always like
that and
no i mean i saw
there were plenty of skaters that would
come in it was just more that i had i
think i had a more consistent
run right so
longevity so so other skates would come
in and out
and they would do well and yeah
sometimes beat me absolutely
like i'm curious like do you sit down
with like a like a tom brady or like do
you sit down with like a michael jordan
or like like
are you all part of a group text or
something
no no like i'm really joking
i have never met michael jordan um i
would love to uh i am
um i'm working with tom brady on this
autograph
io the digital collectibles okay um so i
have a connection to him i haven't
actually met him but
we are working together but when you see
somebody like that is there like a an
understanding that you guys have your
kindred spirits in a way you know like
presidents like can all yes i don't know
i i we come from such different worlds i
don't know if it would be like that i
mean i haven't sat down and but there's
you always hear about like roger federer
and tiger woods being really good
friends and michael jordan being good
friends with tiger because there's a
level of greatness that they understand
maybe a level of fame too but greatness
for sure and uh you especially brady
because you guys are both doing it at
advanced ages where it's like you know
this is supposed to be a young man's
thing and then even when you were doing
the 900 you were like older than most of
the competition if i remember correctly
and you're dominating doing historic
[ __ ] that's never been done there's
something that very very very few people
do
except you guys and there has to be some
kind of connection there
um
i i would think so i might just come
from such a different world of
skateboarding that just wasn't popular
wasn't cool that's we're doing it
against all of us so it's a different
sort of dream that's the fascinating
thing for me like when i was just doing
some research like i
i think that most people's perception is
you do is like you have long floppy hair
and you're wearing like tiny little knee
pads skating in the pools
you you this is the chronology i think
mostly you do a 900
a video game happens yeah and then
you're on a mcdonald's commercial like
they don't realize there's any
dips changed oh absolutely yeah and i
got a lot of that but but like you said
i was like yeah i was 31 when i had 900.
and i had been competing literally for
20 years yeah wow